MALE SPEAKER: Welcome,
everyone, to our next episode
of value investing talks
in our series on investing.
We have a very, very
special guest with us today.
He's traveled all the
way from New Delhi,
where he's a professor-- an
adjunct professor-- at MDI.
He teaches a very popular course
to the MBA students over there
which is titled Behavioral
Finance and Business Valuation.
He also blogs at
Fundoo Professor
and I've really enjoyed reading
some of his articles there.
So the nice thing
about Sunday is
that he's not only a teacher,
he's also a practitioner.
So in investing,
it's very interesting
when teaching and practice meet.
And we are really
looking forward
to learning from your insights
having worn both those hats.
And he's one of the few who eats
his own cooking and teaching
as you could say.
So without any further
ado, ladies and gentlemen,
please join me in
welcoming Sanjay Bakshi.
[APPLAUSE]
SANJAY BAKSHI: Thank you,
Sarab for inviting me here.
It's a pleasure to be here.
It's a wonderful campus and
I'm delighted to be here
with you today.
My talk is titled "The
Prejudices of Mr. Market."
But I would like to talk
to you, first, about
and an unusual subject
called empathy,
which is the ability
to step into the shoes
of another person aiming to
understand his or her feelings
and perspectives, and to
use that understanding
to guide our actions.
Empathy-- normally you
don't associate this word
with the world of
capitalism and investing.
And I have to admit that I
used to take the same way too
when I started out as a value
investor about 21 years ago.
But today I think differently.
Today I think that every value
investor should count empathy
as one of the key tools
in his or her toolkit.
Today I use empathy
to really understand
a business and its
market valuation.
Let me explain how.
I'm a value investor
who focuses on investing
in moated businesses in
public markets in India.
A moat, as you
know, is a metaphor
that Warren Buffett uses
to illustrate the idea
of a competitive advantage.
And in one of his
various talks, he
said that what we're
really trying to find
is a business that, for
one reason or another,
has this moat around it.
And you throw crocodiles and
sharks and piranhas in the moat
to make it harder
and harder for people
to swim across and
attack the castle.
So it's a very
powerful metaphor.
It's quite obvious
to me that investing
in a business with a moat
carries a very low risk
of permanent loss of capital.
A durable competitive
advantage makes a business
resilient to economic shocks
as well as managerial mistakes.
It gives the business what Tom
Russo, a wonderful investor who
I'm told is going to be
here and address you soon,
likes to call this
capacity to suffer.
My own experience of more than
two decades of value investing
has persuaded me that investing
in a business with a moat
is likely to deliver much higher
returns with much lower risk
of permanent loss of capital
than investing in a business
without a moat.
I am also convinced that
buying into scalable businesses
with moats at sensible
prices and then
holding onto them for
long periods of time
is a very profitable,
low-stress investment strategy.
But what about empathy?
How do we use it for
analyzing moated businesses?
Well, while
evaluating a business
for a potential investor,
I try to empathize
with four types of people.
I try to step into
their shoes with an aim
to understand their
feelings and perspectives
and to use their understanding
to guide my firm's actions.
Who are these people?
Well, they're on
the screen here.
The first one, obviously,
is the customer.
I think it's terribly
important to understand well
about the pain of the customer
that a business alleviates.
Why does she prefer to
buy from the company
that you're evaluating?
What's so special about
the value proposition
to customers that
will make them want
to come back again and again?
The second one is
the competitor.
Why would a
particular competitor
not enter this market?
You really have to put yourself
in the shoes of a competitor
and try to enter the market
and see what will happen.
So there are two
kinds of situations
that I have encountered in
a moated situation-- one,
that there is a moat, and people
are going to try to enter,
and they're going to get
hurt, and they're not
going to try again.
And the second one
is that they can't
enter because of some
regulatory reasons--
there is a patent,
for example, or there
is a regulatory monopoly.
What are the entry barriers?
Essentially, this is all
about entry barriers.
And I'm sure you're all very
familiar with all of that.
Put yourself in the shoes
of a potential competitor.
That's what it's all about.
The third person is
the entrepreneur.
What drives the entrepreneur?
Is he what Charlie Munger
calls an intelligent fanatic?
What struggles did he face in
making this business a success?
What would he do
during tough times?
What are his shortcomings?
Are they so strong that you
will reject partnering with him?
Why?
And finally, Mr. Market,
why is the stock market
misunderstanding this business?
What are its prejudices?
What will make them go away?
For the rest of
this talk, I will
focus on the fourth
person, Mr. Market.
The first three
are very obvious.
I think you all
know them very well.
Anybody who has studied
Porter knows about that.
But the fourth
person, Mr. Market, I
think it's something
worth knowing more about.
Many years ago Warren Buffett
called the stock market
the semi-psychotic
creature given to extremes
of elation and despair.
He was referring to the idea
that markets are sometimes very
inefficient in pricing assets.
In his classic book "The
Intelligent Investor,"
Ben Graham uses the
metaphor of Mr. Market,
which Warren Buffett has written
and spoken about many times.
And I quote, "Ben Graham,
my friend and teacher,
long ago described
the mental attitude
towards market fluctuations.
And I believe to be
the most conducive to
investment success.
He said that you should imagine
market quotations coming
from a remarkably
accommodating fellow named
Mr. Market who is your
partner in a private business.
Without fail, Mr. Market
appears daily and names
a price at which he will
either buy your interest
or sell you his.
Even though the business
that the two of you own
may have economic
characteristics that
are stable, Mr. Market's
quotations will be anything
but, for, sad to
say, the poor fellow
has incurable
emotional problems."
"At times he feels euphoric and
can see only favorable factors
affecting the business.
When in that mood, he names
a very high buy/sell price
because he fears that you
may snap up his interest
and rob him of imminent gains.
At other times he's depressed
and can see nothing but trouble
ahead for both the
business and the world.
On those occasions he
will name a very low price
since he's terrified
that you will
unload your interest onto him."
"Mr. Market has another
endearing characteristic.
He doesn't mind being ignored.
If his quotation is
uninteresting to you today,
he'll be back with
a new one tomorrow.
Transactions are
strictly at your option.
Under these conditions,
the more manic
depressive his behavior,
the better for you."
"But like Cinderella
at the ball,
you must heed one warning
or everything will
turn into pumpkin and mice.
Mr. Market is there to serve
you and not to guide you.
It is his pocketbook,
not his wisdom,
that you will find useful.
If he shows up some day in
a particularly foolish mood,
you're free to either ignore
him or take advantage of him.
But it'll be
disastrous if you were
to fall under his influence."
I think every potential value
investor or value investing
student has read
this many times.
So it appears that
Mr. Market really
is what Warren
Buffett has called
"a semi-psychotic
creature given to extremes
of elation and despair."
Yes, he is utterly
irrational sometimes.
And whenever that
happens, value investors
are going to take advantage
of his prejudices.
But here's the thing-- if Mr.
Market is irrational and stays
that way, then how will value
investors make any money?
For them to make
money, Mr. Market
should misprice assets
only temporarily.
And that is exactly
what Ben Graham
meant when he said
that "in the short run,
the market is a voting machine
reflecting a voter registration
test that requires only
money, not intelligence
or emotional stability.
But in the long run, the market
is like a weighing machine."
Therein lies our opportunity.
Once we know, one, that
the stock market has
a tendency of becoming
extremely prejudiced
against some business
which, in our view,
is exceptionally good,
two, such prejudices
produce very attractive market
valuations for that business,
and three, the
market, however, tends
in tendency of correcting
its prejudice over time,
we can really understand how to
make intelligent investments.
If we can understand why
the market is prejudiced
against a business
we love and what
will make those
prejudices go away,
then we'll have a basis for
betting against the market.
That is exactly
what Seth Klarman
meant when he wrote about the
idea of necessary arrogance.
He said that "at
the root of value
investing is the belief,
first espoused by Ben Graham,
that the market is a
voting machine and not
a weighing machine.
Thus an investor must
have more confidence
in his or her own opinion
than in the combined
weight of all other opinions.
This borders on arrogance,
the necessary arrogance
that is required to make
investment decisions."
"This arrogance must be tempered
with extreme caution giving
due respect to the opinions
of others, many of whom
are very intelligent
and hard-working.
Their sale of shares to you
at seeming bargain prices
may be the result of
ignorance, emotion,
or various institutional
constraints.
Or it may be that the apparent
bargain is, in fact, flawed,
that it is actually fairly
priced or even overvalued
and that sellers know
more than you do."
"This is a serious risk, but one
that can be mitigated, first,
by extensive fundamental
analysis, and second,
by knowing not
only that something
is bargain priced but, as best
as you can, also why it is so.
You never know for certain
why sellers are getting out,
but you may be able
to reasonably surmise
a rationale."
I think Klarman has made a
very important point here
about the need to know the
prejudices of Mr. Market.
And many of those
prejudices arise out
of a shortcut called a
representativeness heuristic,
which means that we look
for similar past experiences
to make judgments about the
probability of future events.
So for example, if you run
an insurance operation,
you would have vast
amounts of customer data
that allows you to determine
future likely behavior
of a potential
buyer of insurance.
You would determine
that probability
and accordingly determine
the insurance quotation
based on categories.
You will create these
categories in your database.
A potential buyer of insurance
might, in your judgment,
belong to a high risk
category because he's
a male, 20-year-old,
young, alcohol-consuming,
college-going student who
has never owned a car before.
For such a buyer, your quotation
for selling car insurance
would be higher than that of
a low-risk category individual
comprising of, say, a
35-year-old woman, a mother
of two children who has never
had an accident in her 10
years of car driving experience.
Such type of categorization
or stereotyping
is essential for making quick
judgments in any domain.
Indeed, the very
word "stereotyping"
has an unnecessary
negative connotation.
In Daniel Kahneman's book,
"Thinking, Fast and Slow,"
he writes, "'Stereotyping'
is a bad word in our culture,
but in my usage it is neutral.
One of the basic
characteristics of System 1
is that it represents
categories as norms
and prototypical exemplars."
"This is how we think of
horses, refrigerators,
and New York police officers.
We hold in memory
a representation
of one or more normal members
of each of these categories.
When the categories are
social, these representations
are called stereotypes."
"Some stereotypes are
perniciously wrong
and hostile stereotyping can
have dreadful consequences.
But psychological facts
cannot be avoided.
Stereotypes, both
correct and false,
are how we think of categories."
When Kahneman writes that some
stereotypes are perniciously
wrong, he's referring
to such stereotyping
as a key source of prejudice.
In his wonderful book, "Mistakes
Were Made (But Not by Me),"
the psychologist Elliot
Aronson writes, "Prejudices
emerge from the disposition
of the human mind
to perceive and process
information in categories.
Categories is a nicer, more
neutral word than stereotypes,
but it is the same thing.
Stereotypes are
energy-saving devices
that allow us to make
efficient decisions
on the basis of past
experience, help us quickly
process new information and
retrieve memories, make sense
of real differences
between groups,
and predict, often with
considerable accuracy,
how others will behave
or how they think.
We wisely rely on stereotypes
and the quick information
they give us to avoid danger,
approach possible new friends,
choose one school
or job over another,
or decide that the person
across the crowded room
will be the love of our lives."
But when Kahneman also writes
that hostile stereotyping can
have dreadful
consequences, he is really
referring to sensitive
social contexts
such as hiring and
racial profiling
by, say, immigration
authorities.
He's not referring to
the world of investing.
In the world of investing,
hostile stereotyping
by Mr. Market can have
wonderful consequences
for the value investors.
Take the case of the
airline industry.
Anyone who has read
Warren Buffett's letters
or watched his
interviews on the subject
knows just how bad the economics
of the airline industry are.
WARREN BUFFET: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Mr.
Buffett, what prompted
you to make an investment in
US Air given the fact that this
is such a cutthroat
industry and certainly
not transparent and
easily understandable?
WARREN BUFFET: Well, I think
that, probably, the best answer
is temporary insanity.
[LAUGHTER]
The fellow that runs US
Air is a wonderful guy,
but he just happens to be in an
extraordinarily tough business.
And the interesting
thing is I had actually
written something for Graham's
book, in the early '70s,
about how the airline business
was about the toughest
business there was.
And the interesting
thing of your question
is that if you'd go
back to the time--
and we're in the
right state for that--
if we go back to the
time of Kitty Hawk, net,
the airline transport
business in the United States
has made no money.
I mean, just think if you'd
been down there in Kitty Hawk
and you'd seen this guy go up.
And all of a sudden this vision
hits you that tens of millions
of people would be doing this
all over the world some day
and it would bring us all
closer together and everything.
And you'd think, my god, this
is something to be in on.
And despite putting in billions
and billions and billions
of dollars, the net
return to owners
from being in the entire
airline industry-- if you'd
owned it all and you'd
put up all this money--
is less than zero.
If there had been a
capitalist down there,
the guy should have shot down
Wilbur, you know what I mean?
One small step for
mankind and one huge step
backwards for capitalism.
But anyway, so along comes 1989
and I've got a lot of cash.
And no one misled me in
any way, shape or form.
This is 100% my decision.
And I put money in it.
And Seth Schofield-- you can't
find a better human being
or manager than Seth Schofield.
But he is operating
with revenues
based on market factors
and costs that are not
based on market factors.
And that's a recipe
for a lot of trouble.
So I now have this--
SANJAY BAKSHI: I'll pause
there, for the video.
WARREN BUFFET: --800 number.
And if I ever get the urge
to buy an airline stock--
SANJAY BAKSHI:
Buffett is obviously
talking about the insensitivity
towards base rates.
WARREN BUFFET: --I
dial this number.
And I say, my name is Warren
and I'm an "airoholic."
And then this guy talks
me down on the other end.
SANJAY BAKSHI: He is telling
us that before we invest
in the airline industry,
we should be aware
that the odds of making money
in that industry are bleak.
That's because the overall
economics of the airline
industry suck.
But that does not
have to mean that we
put every airline in the crappy
business category in our mind.
If we do that,
then we will never
invest in a Ryanair or
a Southwest Airline,
both of which are
solid businesses which
have beaten market
indices handsomely
over the last several years.
Perhaps the analyst who did
invest in either of these two
businesses thought
differently from the market
without falling
for the prejudice
of applying the crappy
business label to them.
Perhaps she dug deeper and
found that both businesses
had durable
competitive advantages
and were run by entrepreneurs
whom Charlie Munger would
call intelligent fanatics.
Perhaps she had reliable and
persuasive evidence specific
to those businesses
which would go
against the conclusion
in the base rate
that airlines are
crappy businesses.
Perhaps they were
exceptional businesses
which defied the rule.
Perhaps she had the necessary
arrogance based on the fact
that she was right and
Mr. Market was wrong.
Exactly this type of thinking
produces exceptional returns.
When Mr. Market is
deeply prejudiced
against what you know to
be a wonderful business,
that very prejudice creates
a fabulous investment
opportunity.
And so let's empathize
with Mr. Market
and understand its
prejudices in the pricing
of moated businesses.
But before I do that I want
to say some words of caution.
First, these are the prejudice
that I have found and exploited
over the years, which means
that there may be others
which I have not found yet.
Second, I only to
prejudices in the pricing
of moated businesses.
To be sure, there
are many other ways
of practicing value investing.
And the other kinds
of value investing
may result in your exploiting
opportunities, prejudices which
are very different
from the one which
I'm going to site right now.
Finally, there will be
overlaps in the sense
that, sometimes, you will
find multiple prejudices
in a single situation.
And when that happens, you
can expect what Charlie Munger
calls a lollapalooza outcome.
My first prejudice is
titled "Marshmallows."
Here I want to talk about
the tendency of investors
to categorize
stocks of businesses
as cheap or expensive based on
their reported P/E multiples.
For example, many of my
own value investing friends
wouldn't want to buy
into a business selling
at a P/E multiple of 25.
That's a prejudice in my
view for two big reasons.
First, there's
plenty of evidence
which disconfirms the
notion that business
selling at P/E multiples of
25 or above are expensive.
By definition, a business
that's expensive,
if purchased at that
expensive price,
should deliver poor investment
returns over the long term.
But there's plenty
of research which
shows that's not the case.
While the average business
may well be overpriced at 25x,
that doesn't mean that
exceptional ones are also
expensive at that
market valuation.
Charlie Munger's observation
that "if a business earns
18% on capital over
20 or 30 years,
even if you pay an
expensive looking price,
you'll end up with
one hell of a result"
is obviously
applicable over here.
And the second reason is
that, in a moated business,
reported earnings
often understate
true economic earnings.
That's because money spent
on successful moat expansion
activities is
charged off to P&L.
But it should be treated
as an expenditure
with benefit spanning
more than a year.
This is a key point that
Buffett has made in his letters
and which, in my view, is
often not fully understood
by investors.
Charlie Munger's observation
that almost all good businesses
engage in paying today, gain
tomorrow activities also
means that after making
the necessary adjustments,
one would find that the multiple
of their economic earnings--
the ones that really
matter-- are sometimes
significantly lower
than P/E multiples
based on reported earnings.
And so what looks
optically expensive
is really not that expensive.
In my view, the
market's tendency
to categorize a
business as expensive
simply because it's
trading at a 25 multiple
is an inexplicable prejudice.
Warren Buffett agrees.
He wrote, many years ago, that
the term "value investing"
typically connotes the
"purchase of stocks
having attributes such
as low ratio of price
to book value, price to earnings
ratio at a high dividend
yield."
Unfortunately, such
characteristics,
even if they appear
in combination,
are far from determinative as
to whether an investor is indeed
buying something
for what it is worth
and is therefore truly
operating on the principles
for obtaining value
in his investments.
Correspondingly opposite
characteristics--
a high ratio of price to book
value, a high price/earnings
ratio, and a low
dividend yield--
are in now way inconsistent
with a value purchase.
At this point you
must be wondering,
why did I title this part of
the talk as "marshmallows."
The answer to that question lies
in a famous experiment which
I'm sure many of
you have heard of,
the famous
marshmallow experiment
conducted in the neighborhood
in Stanford University.
This experiment is beautifully
described in this video.
JOACHIM DE POSADA:
I'm here because I
have a very important message.
I think we have found the most
important factor for success.
And it was found close
to here, at Stanford.
A psychology professor took
kids that were four years old
and put them in a room
all by themselves.
And he would tell the child,
a four-year-old kid, Johnny,
I want to leave you here with
a marshmallow for 15 minutes.
If, after I come back,
this marshmallow is here,
you will get another one.
So you will have two.
To tell a four-year-old kid to
wait 15 minutes for something
that they like is
equivalent to telling us,
we'll bring you coffee in two
hours, exactly equivalent.
So what happened when the
professor left the room?
As soon as the door
closed-- [SWISH]--
two out of three
ate the marshmallow.
Five seconds, 10 seconds,
40 seconds, 50 seconds,
two minutes, four
minutes, eight minutes--
some lasted 14.5 minutes--
[SWISH] [CHOMP]--
couldn't do it, could not wait.
What's interesting is
that one out of three
would look at the
marshmallow and go like this.
Would look at it, put it back.
They would walk around.
They would play with
their skirts and pants.
That child already,
at four, understood
the most important principle for
success, which is the ability
to delay gratification,
self-discipline,
the most important
factor for success.
15 years later-- 14, 15 years
later-- follow-up study.
What did they find?
They went to look for these
kids who were now 18 and 19.
And they found that 100%
of the children that
had not eaten the
marshmallow were successful.
They have good grades.
They were doing wonderful.
They were happy.
They had their plans.
They have good relationships
with the teachers, students.
They were doing fine.
A great percentage of the
kids that ate the marshmallow,
there were in trouble.
They did not make it
to the university.
They have bad grades.
Some of them dropped out.
A few were still--
SANJAY BAKSHI: Why did
most kids not wait?
Two out of three
kids didn't wait.
Well, if you think
about it, they
were implicitly using
DCF, discounted cash flow,
to make their choice.
The kid who could not
wait for 15 minutes
for another marshmallow was
implicitly, at the subconscious
level, using a very
high discount rate
to determine the present value
of the second marshmallow.
To her, two marshmallows
15 minutes later
were not worth as much
as one marshmallow now.
And the only way
that can happen is
if she was using a very
high discount rate.
If kids can be
myopic and over-weigh
instant gratification
and under-weigh
delayed gratification,
why not Mr. Market?
Indeed, Buffett offers clues as
to how he thinks about discount
rates for valuing a business.
He says, "When we look at
the future of a business,
we look at riskiness as
a sort of go/no-go valve.
In other words, if we
think that we simply
don't know what's going
to happen in the future,
that doesn't mean it's
risky for everyone.
It means we don't know
and it's risky for us."
"It may not be risky
for someone else
who understand the business.
However, in this
case, we just give up.
We don't try to
predict those things.
We don't say, well, we don't
know what's going to happen.
Therefore we'll
discount the cash flows
that we don't know
at 9% instead of 7%.
That's not a good
way to approach it."
This is very fundamental.
Because what he's
saying is that in order
to value a financial asset, he
uses the same discount rate.
He doesn't use the idea of
equity risk premium at all.
Clearly, Buffett does not
use an equity risk premium
in the discount rate.
He does not heavily
discount distant cash flows,
delayed gratification, like
the children in the marshmallow
experiment.
And that gives him an
edge over competition,
because he can pay
up for quality.
He's not actually
overpaying for it.
The second prejudice I'll
call hidden champions.
This is taken from a wonderful
book called "Hidden Champions."
in this book, the author writes
about extremely successful
businesses that have
been below the radar
for long periods of time,
hidden champions, really.
"Large corporations," he
writes, "are the subject
of close and constant scrutiny
by academic researchers,
analysts, shareholders,
and journalists.
Hidden champions,
on the other hand,
remain a virtually unexplored
source of knowledge."
Scattered about the
globe, thousands
of these highly
successful companies
are concealed behind a curtain
of inconspicuous invisibility
and, in some cases,
deliberate secrecy."
"This applies to the
products these companies make
and how they beat
their competition.
And even more
difficult to research
is how they're
managed internally.
Even their names are
known to only a handful
of experts, consultants,
journalists, and researchers.
This secretiveness
contrasts starkly
with the dominant positions
the hidden champions enjoy
in their markets."
"Many of them have global
market shares of more than 50%
and even hold shares in the
relevant market of 70% to 90%.
On average, they're
more than twice
the size of their
strongest competitors.
Only a few large multinationals
achieve comparable market
positions."
The question that he asks,
I think, is very important.
Why does this happen?
Why do these
outstanding companies
remain below the radar?
He offers many reasons,
but the most obvious one
is that the large number
of the products offered
by hidden champions go
unnoticed by consumers.
"Many of these companies operate
in the hinterland of the value
chain supplying machinery
components or processes that
are no longer discernible in
the final product or service.
As a result, the products
lose their distinct identity
or autonomy."
That's the most
interesting part for me.
The products offered
by hidden champions
go unnoticed by consumers.
Such businesses not only
go unnoticed by consumers,
I think they also go
unnoticed by investors.
A related tendency
of the market is
to categorize all businesses
in a commodity industry
as crappy businesses,
something that I
referred to in the context of
the airline industry just now.
Indeed, some of the best ideas
in which my colleagues and I
have invested have
exploited these prejudices
of Mr. Market-- mispriced
B-to-B businesses which
have business models
as good or even better
than some exceptional
B-to-C businesses
as well as profitable
niches hiding
inside commodity industries.
Indeed, Buffett and
Munger love the idea
of investing in profitable
niche businesses operating
in industries with
commodity characteristics.
For example, Berkshire owns
several profitable niche
insurance operations.
And I quote, "The insurance
industry is cursed with a set
of dismal economic
characteristics that make
for a poor long-term outlook--
hundreds of competitors,
ease of entry, and product that
cannot be differentiated in any
meaningful way.
In such a
commodity-like business,
only the low cost operator
or someone operating
in a protected,
usually small niche
can sustain high
profitability levels."
Charlie Munger has said that,
"in nature and in business,
specialization is key.
Just as in an ecosystem,
people who narrowly specialize
can get terribly good at
occupying some little niche,
just as animals
flourish in niches,
similarly, people who specialize
in the business world--
and get very good
because they specialze--
frequently find good
economics that they wouldn't
find in any other way."
So I think it makes a lot
of sense for investors
to look for profitable niches
in commodity industries which
are priced and-- mispriced,
rather-- as commodity
businesses.
That's the categorization that
the market is applying to them.
That's the label that the market
is applying to them, painting
everything with the same
brush, throwing the baby out
with the bath water.
The third prejudice that I have
is called learning machines.
Now you live in a
world-- you live
in that part of
the world-- where
making mistakes and
encountering failures
is celebrated and is
often a precondition
for getting funding
from VCs or even a job.
The world out there
is actually quite
different from all of this.
Where I come from, Mr. Market
has a prejudice against people
who make mistakes.
For a while, it is
unable to distinguish
between people who make mistakes
and will continue to make them
and people who Charlie Munger
would call learning machines.
In other words,
it has a tendency
of categorizing all mistaken
entrepreneurs as dumb people.
This prejudice doesn't
last forever, of course.
But sometimes it lasts long
enough to make it exploitable.
A few years ago, I invested in
a business which, at one time,
was in bankruptcy but is, today,
one of India's most profitable
listed businesses as measured
by return on invested capital.
The chief cause
of bankruptcy was
a series of mistakes
made by its founder.
Unlike many other entrepreneurs
however, this entrepreneur
was not only candid
about his mistakes,
he was also determined
not to make them again.
And he didn't.
He got rid of a lot
of business that
destroyed value and became
really good at doing
one thing really well.
He outsourced
manufacturing operations
to eight vendors, which
dramatically boosted returns
on capital.
He got out of debt and
has a liquid balance
sheet with surplus cash and has
committed that he will never
borrow money again.
He made a very wise acquisition
at a ridiculously low price
which not only gave him
access to important patented
technology, it also opened
up a new big market for him.
And there was this
period of time
when the market
pretty much ignored
all the lessons he had learned.
And the stock
continued to languish
even though, during that time,
his company became the world's
most dominant player
in that industry.
But as Graham says,
in the long run,
the market is a
weighing machine.
And that's how I treated
this business too.
Today, it is far more
appropriately valued
and it's obvious
that Mr. Market has
overcome its prejudice against
this particular learning
machine.
There's a pattern
here, of course.
I think value investors
should consciously
look for learning machines
which haven't been forgiven
for their past mistakes.
That's a prejudice
worth exploiting.
The fourth one-- I
have five in total--
is called serial acquirers.
It's a well-known fact
that most acquisitions
don't create value.
That's because the acquirers
become overly optimistic
about the prospects of
targets and overestimate
the synergies of acquisitions.
So we know the baseline
information for acquisition
really sucks.
So statistically
speaking, the stock market
is absolutely right to
view serial acquirers
with a great deal of skepticism.
But this doesn't have to mean
that all serial acquirers will
destroy value.
There are a few exceptions.
And sometimes the market
is prejudiced against them.
The market's tendency to
categorize all serial acquirers
as value destroyers is
an exploitable prejudice
in my view.
There are examples.
Let's look at the common factors
in these serial acquirers which
do create value.
There a few examples.
Henry Singleton was one.
Warren Buffett clearly is one.
[INAUDIBLE] financial
is another one.
The common factors,
in my view, are, one,
extreme financial
discipline-- that is,
willingness to walk away from a
deal that doesn't make economic
sense-- two, providing a
permanent home to a promising
business, which is something
private equity funds cannot do,
three, preserving the successful
culture of the acquired
business, and four, providing
growth capital for sensible
inorganic growth through
bolt-on acquisitions.
For value investors,
making an investment
in such a business when the
market is prejudiced against it
makes a lot of economic sense
because of the option value
embedded in such a situation.
Successful serial
acquirers like Berkshire
have carved out a
niche for themselves
to become preferred owners
of wonderful businesses.
This competitive advantage
of sourcing deals
not available to others has
significant option value
over time.
The investor is, in
effect, to borrow
a term coined by
Professor Richard
Zeckhouser in his wonderful
paper titled "investing
in the Unknown and
the Unknowable,"
a sidecar investment,
which is an individual who
has exceptional sourcing skills
and a track record of value
creation through
inorganic growth.
The investor rides
around in a sidecar
pulled by a powerful motorcycle.
The more the investor is
distinctively positioned
to have confidence in
the driver's integrity
and his motorcycle's
capabilities,
the more attractive
the investment.
Prejudice five is called
freaks and misfits.
Now I'm almost sure
you've seen this before.
A few months ago, someone
asked a question on Quora.
The question is on the screen.
And Elon Musk's
ex-wife, Justine,
gave an answer which
went viral and ended up
being quoted by "New
York Times," "Vox,"
CNBC, CNN, "The Huffington
Post," and "Time" magazine.
Here's an excerpt
from her reply.
"Extreme success results
from extreme personality
and comes at the cost
of many other things.
Extreme success is
different from what I
suppose you would call success.
So know that you don't
have to be Richard or Elon
to be affluent and accomplished
and maintain a great lifestyle.
Your odds of happiness
are better that way."
"But if you are
extreme, you must
be what you are, which
means that happiness is
more or less besides the point.
These people tend to be
freaks and misfits who
are forced to experience
the world in an unusually
challenging way.
They develop
strategies to survive.
And as they grew
older, they found ways
to apply these strategies
to other things
and create for themselves a
distinct and power advantage."
"They don't think the
way other people think.
They see things from angles that
unlock new ideas and insights.
Other people consider them
to be somewhat insane."
The term "freaks
and misfits," which
might ring a bell with you given
the culture that we are in,
was taken from Justine.
I think it's important for us
to understand her perspective.
And that is something that a
professor from Harvard Business
School, Joseph Badaracco,
offers an explanation.
Here the professor
uses literary fiction
to teach leadership to the
students at Harvard Business
School.
In this book "Questions
of Character"
he writes, "How
does serious fiction
help us understand leadership?
The answer is simple but
extraordinarily powerful.
Serious fiction gives
us a unique inside view
of leadership.
In real life, most
people see the leaders
of their organizations
only occasionally"--
as investors, this is
exactly what we get to see.
We don't get to see what is
really happening-- "and only
get a fleeting glimpse of what
these leaders are thinking
and feeling."
"Even interviews with
executives have limits.
Executives only say so much.
And even when they
want to be candid,
sensitivities have
to be observed,
memory fades and
sometimes distorts,
and success crowds out failures.
In contrast, serious literature
offers a view from the inside.
It opens doors to a world
rarely seen except, on occasion,
by leaders' spouses
and closest friends."
Think Justine Musk.
"It lets us watch
leaders as they
think, work, hope, hesitate,
commit, exalt, regret,
and reflect.
We see their characters
tested, reshaped, strengthened,
or weakened."
The reason why Justine's
perspective is important for us
is because, as the
professor puts it,
"it opens doors to a
world rarely seen, except,
on occasion, by leaders'
spouses and closest friends."
In my view, when it
comes to evaluating
the quality of extremely
successful entrepreneurs
in the early part
of the journey,
the market displays a prejudice.
This prejudice is
derived not only
from the complex
personality that some
of these entrepreneurs have,
many of the whom are definitely
not likable people, but
also from a limited view
about the individual in
question that investors get.
I've seen this prejudice
play out over and over again.
The market is just too
judgmental about some of them.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CAR HORN]
[DOG BARKING]
-Look at the cute dog.
-All the boys are
calling, crazy girl.
-I hope she sings this tonight.
-I know.
-Hey dad, pull over.
We need gum.
-I'm on it.
Oh, honey, here's some money.
-What do we get here?
[POLICE SIREN]
-Hello.
[END PLAYBACK]
SANJAY BAKSHI: I see this
play out over and over again
in analyzing these human beings,
extraordinary human beings.
The reality is that
the riding on the coat
tails of such
extraordinary human beings
is a key source of
compounding capital
for public market investors.
Charlie agrees.
In an interview with Miguel
Barbosa of Simoleon Sense,
successful value
investor Paul Lountzis
has said, "The ability
to identify a young Phil
Knight, a young Howard
Shultz from Starbucks,
a young John Mackey
from Whole Foods
is becoming
increasingly important."
I'm typically attracted to a
company because of the numbers.
But what makes you enormously
successful for your clients
is when you identify
qualitative factors that
are yet to appear in the
quantitative results.
The key is to identify
these situations early.
You still have those
opportunities when companies
are small, but it's getting
harder because there
are many smart people looking.
For example, if you see
Progressive Insurance
generating an 82
combined ratio and making
$0.18 on every dollar
on their underwriting
before investment income,
you might say, my god,
State Farm is at 110.
How are these guys
so profitable?
It's really hard to
identify these unique teams
and cultures.
But if you can do
it or get lucky,
then you can do very
well for your clients.
By having an edge, you
will avoid overpaying.
You're protected on the downside
and you have enormous upside
because you're piggybacking
on a visionary who's building
an extraordinary culture.
With the long-run way,
because of this mispricing,
you can stay with
them for 20 years.
Furthermore, because you
have done your research,
and you understand how
this visionary is building
the business, and you
have the confidence
to survive all the vicissitudes
of the market, when you
go through tough
times, you recognize
they have a stable
competitive advantage.
They've got better
people, they're tenacious,
and they're likely
to come out stronger.
It's an important
distinction that I'm
trying to make that
the qualitative is
becoming more important.
I still think
quantitative features are
subordinate to the business
model in valuation,
but the business model
is infinity more impacted
by management and culture
than it was in the past.
I think it's terribly
important for value investors
to recognize that a key
source of investment success
is to become long-term
passive partners
with extraordinary human
beings who many would
regard as freaks or misfits.
When George Bernard Shaw said
that "the reasonable man adapts
himself to the world;
the unreasonable one
persists in trying to
adapt the world to himself.
Therefore all progress depends
on the unreasonable man,"
was he talking about
freaks and misfits?
Shouldn't the label of freak
and misfit not sometimes
be relabeled as
intelligent fanatics?
That's what this bias is
about, the representativeness
heuristic, labels.
We apply labels.
And a label of a
freak and misfit,
which is a negative
connotation, can easily
be sometimes relabeled as
an intelligent fanatic.
And it makes all the difference.
One of my key learnings
from studying such people
is that, as an investor, I have
to teach myself to overlook
many of their personality
traits, some of which
are not admirable at all.
Indeed, I think those
traits are a consequence
of their fanatic
focus on their work.
I have been consciously
training myself
to empathize with such
extraordinary human beings.
In his wonderful book
"The Social Animal,"
Elliot Aronson talks about the
insidious nature of prejudice.
He quotes a fictional
dialogue from Gordon Allport's
classic book "The
Nature of Prejudice."
I think the dialogue
is worth reading.
Mr. X says that "the
trouble with Jews
is that they only take
care of their own group."
Mr. Y, who's the prejudiced
person, says-- sorry,
Mr. X is the prejudiced person.
Mr. Y is the interrogator.
He says, "But the record of
the Community Chest campaign
shows that they give
more generously,
in proportion to their numbers,
to the general charities
of the community
than do non-Jews."
Mr. X then responds,
"That shows they're always
trying to buy favor and
intrude into Christian affairs.
They think of nothing but money.
And that's why there are
so many Jewish bankers."
Mr. Y responds,
"But a recent study
shows that the percentage of
Jews in the banking business
is negligible, far smaller than
the percentage of non-Jews."
Mr. X then responds,
"That's just it.
They don't go in for
respectable businesses.
They're only in
the movie business
or they run nightclubs."
The dialogue illustrates
the insidious nature
of prejudice far better than
the mountain of definitions.
In effect, the prejudiced
Mr. X is saying,
don't trouble me with the facts.
My mind is made up.
He makes no attempt to
dispute the data presented
by Mr. Y. He either
distorts the facts in order
to make them support
his hatred of Jews
or he bounces off
them, undaunted,
to a new area of attack.
A deeply prejudiced
person is virtually
immune to information
at variance
with his or her
cherished stereotypes.
As famed jurist Oliver
Wendell Holmes, Jr. once said,
"Trying to educate a bigot
is like shining light
into the pupil of an
eye-- it constricts."
Whlie Aronson's words, that
a deeply prejudiced person
is virtually immune to
information at variance
with his or her
cherished stereotypes,
apply to many
prejudiced human beings,
they do apply, if you think
about it, to Mr. Market.
That's because Mr. Market
is a learning machine.
He corrects his
prejudices over time.
While the five patterns
of prejudice that I just
outlined they keep coming
back in one form or the other,
the prejudice against
specific examples
conforming to these patterns
tends to disappear over time.
We have a name for that,
and we call that rerating.
I think there are
two lessons here.
The first one I've
already told you about.
The second one is that
we should look at Mr.
Market with some respect.
After all, he's far
less prejudiced than us.
Why couldn't we learn to get rid
of some of our own prejudices
from him.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you, Sanjay.
This was great.
So we'll open up to some
questions right now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Sanjay,
for the wonderful presentation.
I had a question about
the last one, misfits,
and maybe a little bit
about the learning machines.
If we take Warren
Buffett as an example,
you could say, ignoring
the past decade,
most of the
investments he's made
are in a handful of companies,
Geico, American Express
in the beginning, in the
'60s, American Express again
in the '90s, and a
few handful of others.
Almost all of them he bought
at points of maximum pessimism.
I can't maybe recollect
any example where he said,
everything is great
with the business.
And here's a misfit.
Here's a learning machine.
And I'm going to buy it.
I think Coke may be
one such example.
But there are more examples
where it was essentially,
he was focused on the long term,
there was something temporarily
wrong with the business,
and he bought it.
He talks about jumping
one-foot hurdles.
Sounds to me this is more
than a one-foot hurdle,
identifying a misfit
or a learning machine.
But maybe I don't
know any examples.
Maybe you can enlighten us.
SANJAY BAKSHI: Sure.
I think it's
important to recognize
that the examples that
you cited refer to what
he's done in public markets.
And what he does in
public markets actually
is a very small portion of
what actually really happens
in Berkshire.
As you probably
know, they have, I
think, more than
80 businesses now,
in their portfolio, which they
own wholly or almost wholly.
And they have been
generating a lot of cash.
So there have been
all these businesses.
When I talked about
the idea of misfits,
I was really referring
to the apprehensions
that public market investors
have about the character
of these people.
Sometimes these people do things
which look very, very odd.
And they odd in the since
that, after all, these
are extraordinary human beings.
They don't do things
which look ordinary.
And I'm not talking
about innovation.
Of course that is one aspect.
I'm not talking about risk
taking, or innovation, or any
of that.
I'm talking about
things that appear
to be sometimes
unethical, but they really
are not a big deal in the
whole totality of things.
So I'll give an example
without naming names.
There are businesses
which I have
looked at in the past where
the entrepreneur may have paid
himself a really nice salary.
Now if you focus
only on that aspect--
and it may turn out to be
something like 10% of profits.
But the fact of the
matter is that he's
an extraordinary human being.
And 10% does look big.
But if you look at the
overall situation--
if you look at the fact
of what he's accomplished
and the kind of moat
that he has built--
in the totality of
things, you just suck up.
And you have a choice.
Either you want to be a
partner with him or not.
But I think the
opportunity cost of not
being a partner with a guy like
him, an extraordinary person,
is actually quite high.
So you have to swallow
a lot of things
which may, under
normal circumstances,
be something that you might
want to walk away from.
And the reason is because
of the extraordinary moat
that he has created.
So that's just one example.
I'll give you a
few other examples.
I know of a business where
the premier credit rating
company in the country
resigned the assignment.
Why?
Because he's not cooperating.
He basically told
them, buzz off.
I'm not going to give
you the information.
And if you remember,
Charlie Munger
did pretty much the same
thing with the auditors
in "Daily Journal."
And he had a huge tiff
with the auditors.
That's the point I'm making.
These guys have
what Charlie Munger
called a lot of chutzpah.
They absolutely
don't give a shit
about what anybody
else thinks about them.
They think they're
absolutely right.
And it reminds me of what
Charlie Munger has said, never
underestimate a man who
overestimates himself.
And all entrepreneurs
overestimate themselves.
And overconfidence is a very
important aspect of capitalism.
What I'm trying to distinguish
is between the dumb fanatics
and the intelligent fanatics.
And I gave a talk
sometime back when
I made that distinction
where I profiled
seven intelligent
fanatics from India.
And I gave a kind
of a checklist as
to how I think about intelligent
fanatics versus dumb fanatics.
So one of them is debt
or risk management.
So a dumb fanatic
would-- they're
all overconfident whether
you're dumb or not.
But they bet the bank.
And sometimes they get lucky.
Most of the time, they blow up.
So they don't know anything
about risk management.
Whereas an intelligent fanatic
would make a series of bets.
He's, like, writing insurance.
And many of those
bets will fail.
But even if all
of them fail, that
doesn't destroy the company.
So that's one.
The other is they
almost certainly don't
rely on other people's money.
They use their own capital.
They don't borrow money.
So they don't create
financial structures
where they are dependent upon
the kindness of strangers
over there.
So I see that.
I see fanaticism, when
combined with intelligence,
that combined together, makes
a very nice combination.
You see that it's so rare.
If you look at the history
of wealth creation,
when you find this
fanaticism with intelligence
and integrity-- when you
combine those three--
and if you can get it along
with a reasonable business--
and that's the point
I'm making here,
which is the point that even
in commodity industries,
some entrepreneurs
have the ability
to carve out a niche which
is very hard to copy.
And that niche is coming
from the fanaticism
of the entrepreneur.
As it's a very smart person.
And therefore, if you can
become partners with him
on favorable terms in terms
of valuation and all of that,
then you can ignore a lot of
other things, which is what
Elon Musk's ex-wife was saying.
They are crazy in many ways.
These guys-- or women-- they
are very nutty in many ways.
But I think you should not
over-focus on those matters.
You should only focus on the
track record-- what they do,
how they run their
business operations.
MALE SPEAKER: So
if I can just push
that question a
little bit further--
SANJAY BAKSHI: Yes, Soreb.
MALE SPEAKER: So not to say
that there are no intelligent
fanatics and so on, but to
borrow that phrase of whether
it is actually a one-foot
hurdle versus a six-foot hurdle,
so to say--
SANJAY BAKSHI: It
doesn't have to be.
You see, the point is if
you're going to-- what
are we trying to do here?
We're trying to
compound capital, right?
We are doing it
sitting in our offices
in an air-conditioned
environment
without stepping out or actually
[INAUDIBLE] try to become rich.
So it shouldn't be easy.
I don't think the
idea of compounding
capital at superlative
rates of return
over long periods of time
should become extraordinarily
easy for anybody.
If it was, then those
returns will go away.
So I don't think it
should be that easy.
When Mr. Buffett talks
about one-foot hurdles,
he's talking about
his ability to predict
the fundamental
economics of a business
over a long period of time.
And believe it or
not, many businesses
that he has invested in
are actually quite complex.
So for a lot of
people, the ability
to understand supercar
insurance is actually
very, very different.
But he has done that.
So he defines a
circle of competence
and he tries to stay within
that circle of competence.
And I think that's a
wonderful model to have.
But to assume that you will
find very simple things
to do all along, I think that's
something which I don't really
believe in.
AUDIENCE: I have a
two-part question.
Why is it that the
stereotyping-- is
it correct or incorrect--
is often found in hindsight,
with the benefit of hindsight.
With the disparities that
you listed, all five of them,
are there certain tips or
shortcuts, further shortcuts,
which you can tell to
distinguish between what
could be an incorrect
assessment of opportunities
which the market could
correlate over time?
Like, how would you distinguish
between luck and skill
and define this?
SANJAY BAKSHI: Track record.
Track record.
You're really looking at
the long-term track record.
If it was all luck, then
over a period of time,
that would go away, right?
What I'm trying to
illustrate is the point
that there are these
patterns that play out.
What we're trying to
do is if we picked
one-- I picked this one
heuristic, the representative.
There are many others.
I just picked one
and I tried to think
about the various manifestations
in which it occurs,
which creates tradable
opportunities for public market
investors.
What I found was that the
whole idea of labeling-- and I
mentioned that some time ago,
that intelligent fanatic is
just a label.
To somebody else, it might
look like a freak person.
But to somebody else, it could
be an intelligent fanatic.
But what is the truth?
The truth lies in the numbers.
The truth lies in what
they actually accomplish.
So what we're really
looking at is, for example,
in an industry with sub-normal
profitability-- take airlines.
We saw that-- there is
one company which has
extraordinary profitability.
So we all question why,
why is that happening.
Is this luck or is this skill?
And to answer that,
you have to look
at the record over a
long period of time.
You have to look at the
track record of that business
during periods when the
airline industry was
going through a
horrible period of time.
And if you do that for
Ryanair and for Southwest,
you will find that they had some
unusual fundamental financial
performance even during
periods when the entire airline
industry in the world was
going through a terrible phase.
So you try to look for
exceptional, outstanding
performance over
long periods of time.
And then you attribute
that to luck or skill.
And occasionally, you
will find that there
is some skill out there.
The beauty is that the market
is not able to distinguish that.
The market has this
labeling problem.
The market thinks, oh,
it's a crappy business
because it's in the
airline industry
and because Warren
Buffett says so.
Therefore it should not be
priced as a real good quality
business.
But if we ignore for the
moment, if you de-bias yourself,
if you remove the name, the
label of the airline industry
and think like a
Graham, who said,
once, I want to be
completely unbiased.
I don't want to even know
the name of the business,
if you just look at the
actual objective data,
you will find staggering
financial performance.
You won't know what
the industry is.
Just because you know that the
industry is an airline industry
and there is this label
hovering around in your head
that airlines are,
generally speaking--
and that's a correct
label-- crappy businesses,
you tend to misjudge
what you are seeing.
And I think that's a bias
that is worth getting out of,
because that's an
exploitable bias.
That's a bias that the market
will, itself, get out of,
which is where the
opportunity lies.
Because you are
trying to buy it when
the market still has that bias.
And when the market doesn't, the
stock would have been rerated
and you would have
made a lot of money.
You see, the whole idea
in my work in investing
in modern businesses,
what I found
was the idea that moats can
only be found in some industries
and never in other industries,
that itself is a prejudice.
If you work hard enough,
even in businesses
which have commodity labels,
you will find moated businesses,
usually in niches.
And when you find
them, you may often
find that the market
is still treating them
as a commodity business.
That's the opportunity.
AUDIENCE: So you spoke
about many value investors
shying away from buying 25x
multiples and higher than that.
And I think you also spoke about
intelligent fanatics and people
who are driven and obsessed by
growth and returning profits.
I guess the question
I have is, where
does a healthy margin of
safety come into all of this.
I think one of the reasons I
shy away from a 25x multiple
is, what's my margin
of safety, right.
I look at the previous
pace it's been trading at.
I look at its growth.
When I'm buying something
at a P/E value of 25,
I'm expecting 10%, 15%
growth year-on-year
for the next decade, right?
So I just wanted to hear
your thoughts on that.
SANJAY BAKSHI: Sure.
I'll answer that in two parts.
Firstly, when you think
about P/E multiple,
the P part is obvious because
it's observed from the market.
It's the E part which
is quite subjective.
And I mentioned
this-- in my judgment,
in many moated
businesses, the E part
is higher than what you
see over there for reasons
that I explained.
And when you make
those adjustments,
then what looks expensive
is not that expensive.
It's cheaper.
That's one.
Secondly, if you look at a
business that generally has
a moat-- that means it
has strong entry barriers
and it has the ability
to compound capital
at lucrative rates for
long periods of time--
if you do the math, as
Charlie has mentioned,
even if you pay a 25 P/E
multiple for a business which
is compounding capital
internally at a fabulous rate
and has reinvestment
opportunities,
it's the duration
of the opportunity.
If you extend that from five
years to 10 years, and from 10
to a longer period if
you have that conviction,
then it becomes
quite attractive.
I think you may be
referring to some businesses
in this part of the word where
the growth rates are actually
lower.
Where I come from, growth
rates in many business
are actually very high.
They are sometimes in high
double-digit percentage
numbers.
AUDIENCE: In the context of
investing in Asian countries,
two things that
come up and which
cloud every other kind of
judgment for right or wrong
is the authenticity of
what you see on the books.
So first of all, a company
could be doing well
for 10 years, 20 years.
And these are very,
very big numbers.
Some company is doing
good for two decades.
And eventually
something blows up.
And what you figure out is
that was a very, very big fraud
going on.
It could be numbers, could be
because the auditors were being
bribed and all those things.
It happens more
in Asian countries
than, probably, North America.
SANJAY BAKSHI: Is
that a prejudice?
AUDIENCE: Could be.
But when you're identifying
an individual company
and you see returns
which far surpass
the returns of other companies
in the same industry,
one thing that one also
needs to scrutinize
is, is there some
kind of a fraud that's
going on over there.
SANJAY BAKSHI: Absolutely.
That's the whole point
of being an analyst is
that you have to be skeptical.
You have to have the diligence.
You have to be able
to check the numbers.
You have to do
background checks.
There are a lot
of things that you
need to do to make sure
that the numbers are right.
If the numbers are not
right, then obviously
you shouldn't be
investing in that anyway.
Because if they
can cook the books,
then you really don't
want to be a partner
in a business run by a person
who is cooking the books,
right?
So I think it's
absolutely imperative
that you do that test.
And it doesn't matter
which country you are in.
I think that there
was a Madoff here
and there was an
Enron here as well.
So it's something that
is a required discipline
for any value investor,
to be able to do ascertain
whether the numbers
are cooked or not.
AUDIENCE: So how to do that in--
SANJAY BAKSHI: I can do
a whole course on that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SANJAY BAKSHI: Yeah, but
we can talk after this.
There are some things.
It depends on the industry.
If you have to do that
in the banking industry
it becomes far more complex.
It's a very different
kind of business model.
If you're looking at a
simpler business model then
there are ways of doing that.
And I'll be happy to talk
to you after about this.
MALE SPEAKER: So because
this was a central point
in, at least, the last half
of your talk, some of us
were at the "Daily
Journal" meeting
where Charlie Munger was asked
a question about Elon Musk.
So I have a couple of the
sentences from Bloomberg
Business's website.
And Charlie says, "I think
Elon Musk is a genius,
and I don't use
that word lightly.
He's also one of the boldest
men who ever came down the pike.
So put me down as
saying I've always
been afraid of the guy whose IQ
is 190 and he thinks it's 250."
So like you said,
never underestimate
a person who is overconfident.
But I think identifying
intelligent fanatics,
so to say, versus investing
in Tesla or [INAUDIBLE],
aren't they two
separate questions?
SANJAY BAKSHI: They are
very different questions.
All I'm looking at
is, without giving up
on Buffett kind of
thinking, without giving up
on the idea of investing
in highly profitable,
dominant businesses which are
already making a lot of money
and paying reasonable
multiples of their earning
power, particularly when they're
run by an intelligent fanatic,
is a great combination.
I'm not recommending
Tesla, nor am I
recommending Amazon.com
or any of the businesses
that you might relate to the
idea of intelligent fanatics.
I'm just saying,
because you can easily
relate to those human
beings, that there
are these people out there.
They're not as well known
as these human beings are.
But there are these
people out there.
They are achieving
global dominance.
And it's just a label.
The point I'm trying to
make is that this whole talk
was aboard labels,
labels as prejudices.
And therefore,
sometimes a prejudice
which is labeled as
a freak or a misfit,
actually, the correct
label to apply to that
is that of an
intelligent fanatic.
And it doesn't have
to be an Elon Musk.
It doesn't have
to be a Jeff Bezos
or anybody for that matter.
It has to be somebody
who's really passionate,
has got integrity,
is completing driven,
is not dumb in the sense that
it will not blow up the balance
sheet on a single idea, it will
not lever up the balance sheet.
It's conservative and
aggressive in a combination that
is reflective of intelligence.
And if you can find
that combination along
with a great business or
even a reasonable business,
that's the point of making.
You don't have to look for
the best quality businesses
out there because
they get priced out.
In a parimutual system
of the stock market,
you can't bet on
the best horses.
Because the best
horses, the odds change.
You are betting against
other investors.
And therefore, what you
should really be trying to do
is find reasonable
quality businesses which
have the taint of a
commodity on them,
but the particular business
that you are looking at
is an exception.
It's an exception
because it's run
by a fellow or a bunch of people
who are really exceptional.
And you have got data
to validate that.
You're not just dreaming it up.
You're not just seeing it
because you read a prospectus
on an IPO, and you think that
he will do wonderful things,
and you believe he'll
do wonderful things.
You actually have
seen that information.
You've seen that
they have actually
delivered, under
terrible conditions,
fundamental performance which
is outstanding in relation
to their peers in the industry.
And you think that
you can attribute that
to certain causal factors
that you can identify.
And those factors will
remain for a long, long time.
If you can find that with a
reasonable valuation, even
in a normal industry-- not
an extraordinary profitable
industry where
everybody makes money--
I think it's a wonderful
combination, because the market
is mispricing it.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
So thank you, Sanjay,
for a fantastic talk.
It was a pleasure
to have you here.
SANJAY BAKSHI: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]